hello everybody um and good morning good
afternoon or good evening depending
where you are
in the world today and uh wherever you
are around the globe i hope everyone is
keeping safe and well under current
circumstances
i'd like to
now take some time to
talk with you about the importance of
working with your
cmo during
product
development
how the cmo
can help you can assist you and really
facilitate that development process to
make sure your test gets to market when
you want it to get there and
at a at a cost and budget that is in
line with your expectations
so before i dive into
that detail
i would just like to
uh
take a couple of moments
just to
give you an introduction really as to
who and where we are and what we do
essentially so
i guess everyone everybody would would
agree that 2020 has been
a relatively uh challenging year so far
and
they have been i guess significant
changes
for
everyone around the world
there have been a number of changes
within uh habit and health i mean
over since the beginning of 2020 uh
where we are now it's almost a complete
a completely different company in terms
of
what we have facility wise
so just to give you a quick sort of
rundown regarding that so
beginning of this year we had
the one manufacturing site where we also
had r d tech transfer
sales and marketing finance essentially
our headquarters and that was at the
york biotech campus
athuma is outside the historic city of
york in the uk and it's a
biosecure site and we had been there for
a number of years now
one of the challenges that 2020 through
witness was a requirement to
significantly ramp up our
production capacity you know to meet the
demand
for
tests relating to the global pandemic
but also to keep in line with our
customers
business growth so
to that end there's been significant
investment at abundance so we now have a
second manufacturing site which is based
in doncaster um in in the uk
and we still have a uh
satellite r d facility based in the west
midlands
that expansion hasn't just been if you
like for uh the manufacturing footprint
and the actual
square meterage they have
also been
significant uh
investment in terms of people and the
required equipment so if you
are uh
if you have been involved within the the
lateral flow world previously or
something that you were not researching
you you would have very heard uh brand
names such as uh biodog ginolis
kinematic
etcetera so
we've invested heavily in uh new uh
biodot realtory region dispensing
equipment auto laminators and we have
we'll have
multiple genola systems
uh live before the end of the year which
uh very uh which
are very much the um
cutting edge really in that sort of
final assembly piece when assembling the
latter flow asset device
because of the nature of the business
we're involved with as you would imagine
our sites meet all quality standards and
certifications
required and
[Music]
we've
basically grown since 2008 by um
acquiring complementary diagnostic
businesses
not not only to strengthen our position
within this particular market but also
really to enhance the offering uh
that is open to to our customers not be
it for contract development and then
manufacturing or pure contract contract
manufacturing
in terms of
what we do
as i previously mentioned it's there is
a choice um
flexibility is key basically so we have
a global client base
uk europe north america far east
and we essentially are a contract
manufacturing organization specializing
in rapid tests specifically lateral flow
assays
we also have a contract development
component to that so we can be involved
if you like directly in the development
from start to finish then transfer to
manufacturing or it can be pure contract
manufacturing after the test has been
developed
elsewhere
however
regardless of at what point we're
involved and what we are responsible for
we always have the same core focus so
we're relatively unique within the
market in that you know we
have developed and manufacture some of
our own ambulant health branded tests
and
the quality management system processes
procedures that we would apply to our
own developments and old manufacturing
is something that we apply to
our customers also
so that core core focus is very much um
high quality robust manufacturable tests
and that's something that we will touch
upon
a little later but you know it's
something which really cannot be
stressed
enough
the best test in the world
could be developed
every bell and whistle you could
possibly hope for
but actually when you come to
manufacture that test
if that consideration hasn't been there
from very early on you may find that
it's it just simply can't cannot be
manufactured for a reasonable cost that
is going to enable you to hit your
market pricing you know and and
obviously can have a major negative
impact on the performance of our test
within the market and your business
plans so we very much focus on robust
high quality manufacturable tests
everyone can think uh challenges and
issues that that uh present themselves
during development are unique to that
development but we've been involved in
this field for um
long enough time and across a multiple
different uh industry sectors you know
to know that
there isn't much that can be uh that can
kind of challenge us that we haven't
seen previously and you know we would
have something in in our metaphorical uh
toolbox that could be used so
in terms of the different industries we
have developed and we manufacture tests
for
human health
animal and veterinary
agricultural environmental food and food
safety infectious disease and
environmental diagnostics so
each of those different type of tests
can have different challenges in in
terms of how the sample matrix
maybe may be collected may be processed
how the sample matrix will impact
perhaps the biological reagents
etcetera so
any good symbol with its salt you know
will
will have a strong pedigree in in terms
of
manufacturing a wide variety of tests
you know and they may have a history of
test development also so there is
potentially a great source
of
information and assistance as you move
through your own particular
development
over recent years uh we have developed
the uh appdx technology also so and
that's that was simply um a response to
the requirement from our customer base
to perhaps move away from uh
benchtop-based lateral flow
readers more towards a
smartphone based
system so
we
that's something that we've been
involved with for um
a number of years and really
how that uh appdx looks and is
customized uh
for your particular test or a particular
test is very much up to um
your requirements and what you want the
end user to see and how you want them to
use on that smartphone reading so you
can build in things such as
test choreography timers barcode readers
etc or have something that simply
takes the result displays it to the user
and stores it and stores it in within
the phone memory on the other end of the
scale uh
having cloud connectivity and then that
data being accessible by uh
very uh
security um via a secure portal
by for example
a
clinician to assess
the uh progression of a particular
disease state of things or things of
that nature
so
i was just giving a quick quick
introduction as to as to why i'm
basically here today um
i personally have been involved in the
lateral flow um field for
probably come up to
eight years now um i believe and
although uh i do have a background in
science i was a humble microbiologist
for many years before um venturing into
biotech and r d um and rapid test
development it's been a good 20 years
since i last worked within a laboratory
so you will be um you will be pleased to
know our r d director has told me on
numerous times that
i will never set foot into one of her
laboratories so so you can rest assured
um
your the transfer to manufacturing if
needed is done with a safe pair of hands
and you don't get me involved at the
same time
so
but why
why outsource lateral flow assay
production
there's
a number of different areas to
consider really so
there's a financial benefit so for
example if
lateral flow assay production is not
your core business um by outsourcing
that manufacturing
you're then removing the requirement for
quite significant quite heavy capital um
expenditure that budget may be then used
for other purposes perhaps revenue
generated uh
project uh
projects
and of course
it isn't enough just to have the
equipment uh we know from experience you
can have the best equipment in the world
but you've really got to invest in your
people also and
although much of lateral flow assay
production you know can be as automated
as as possible you still need operate as
a production staff of
a high skill level and many with a
scientific background at you to be able
to
manufacture those tests to meet the
specification agreed prior to the whole
thing transferring in
so by outsourcing you're taking away
that people cost also
obviously if lasher flow asset
production isn't your core business
then by outsourcing the manufacturing
you can then focus on on on your core
business you know aligning those
activities with high priority projects
for example and really enabling your
workforce your colleagues to do what
they do best so if that is r d
then
crack on with the r d don't worry about
the manufacturing outsource it to a
company that is trade and trade um
is tried and tested and trusted
within the business
there's very much that element of um
future future proofing the business so
so for example um within any
manufacturing
agreement
there will be agreed quality criteria
quality specifications qc testing uh
agreed lead time
delivery times etc so you know when you
pl when the order is placed for
the required number of tests
they're going to be delivered by the
agreed to by the agreed delivery date i
know and there's no
issue or challenge for you in the future
by losing key personnel involved in um
the manufacture of those tests if you're
doing them in-house and how that could
impact the business so by outsourcing
business you outsource the risk at
essentia which is something that um
a number of people have taken advantage
of uh
over the years because it really is
it can really be a very positive impact
on uh your future business activity
of course
flexing you the operation in line
with demand so
tests transfer in there will be
a routine manufacturing batch size but
but essentially you only need to
purchase what you want in line in line
with your sales forecast
and
if any
cmo
um
[Music]
is worth
doing business with then they they will
already have
um
supply agreements with major materials
manufacturers
so you can really then implement a fixed
cost
management process you know
there should not be any unexpected
spikes in terms of material in the
materials cost
if you have if your cmo has those
agreements in place as the relationships
there and can then manage that manage
that process for you
again really this is all about i guess
outsourcing um
risk again and really why you reinv why
reinvent the wheel so by using a good
cmo they will already have the equipment
in place i mean here you've got a couple
of images of
the genoa system they will have
established processes they will they
will be certified you know with various
regulatory bodies to um
i've already got the people there so
you've got the equipment you've got your
people and you've got the processes all
already in place no need for you to
spend money spend time um to put those
in into your facility so it takes away
any
time associated with ordering equipment
for the best will in the world
sometimes a bottleneck can be
equipment lead time
so
take away that
and of course
any spikes in
demand you know can be quite easily
handled by your cmo as long as you've
done the due diligence side of things
you've chosen a cmo which has the
capability to
really respond to
pressures the market may exert on you
perhaps in terms of
increase in batch size increasing the
number of batches needed or a relatively
short space time you know so the shabo
has to have that has to have that some
capability that footprint necessary to
if need be in in
increased production to meet to meet
your requirements
how can a cmo
assist you otherwise well
use the user schema to become more
competitive you know to do that if you
want stable long-term pricing so as i
said previously your cmo should have a
robust um strong supply chain in in
place
and
can make use of that existing supply
chain and uh
logistical processes in place to make
sure that you've got that long-term
manufacturing cost you're not going to
be
experienced unexpected um spikes in in
terms of in terms of cost and it allows
you to plan properly and also allows
your cmo
to plan and really
unreally um uh
enhances you know which the the
partnership which you know it
really it really should be
something i'll talk about a little bit
later you know is that
you
cmo shouldn't just
be a manufacturer insight you know cmo
should really be your
eyes and ears
within the marketplace so
there may be regulatory support required
which certainly has been for and a
number of companies
recently with the changes to uh uh
european regulation now
they make
logistical support so
rather than the cmo expecting you to
supply all the raw materials um
biologicals the componentry and they
manufacture and then ship and they ship
back to you to ship on to the customer
there may be a requirement just simply
because of available space within your
facility that actually
the cmo will
will handle um the supply chain the
logistics for
all of the components
of your test um you know there may even
even be areas in terms of commercial
activity that that your cmo could
assist you with
perhaps access in different markets
through existing distribution
um and channel sales networks the cmo
already has
etc and i guess the
the last area i would touch upon really
is again it's about that outsourcing the
risk it's it's the support and
reassurance so you will obviously have
within a cmo a dedicated project team
that may handle the transfer of your
tests into routine manufacturing but you
would have a dedicated account manager
there would be points of contact within
quality qcqa
um operations
and those regular routine calls business
reviews
etc you can make sure that your
cmo activity is aligned fully with your
business goals which has been which
really can't be emphasized uh stressed
enough during the current situation with
uh the global pandemic you know that
they
read there's had to have been a much
greater cooperation and contact between
uh customers and cmo
to make sure that
those tests are delivered where they're
needed um to the right people
so
i think we sort of covered why there may
be a requirement to outsource lateral
flow assay production and some of the
benefits outsourcing the production can
um
give
but
i guess we should talk about well when
should the cmo be be involved now
i from
from my perspective um and from my
personal opinion um i would say as early
as possible um
there has to be that focus in
development from a very very early stage
how that test is going to be
manufactured how that test that our
the r d scale those are bench scale
production how is that going to be
scaled up
materials
processes equipment all need to be
considered as a very very
early stage and so
otherwise you're simply not going to
achieve high throughput
production
and
the capability to produce
routinely high quality robust tests
to meet your desired timeline to get
into the market uh to get a foot in the
door
essentially versus versus your
competition
now
how can the cmo
assist you well
at those early stages there may not be
any direct experimental work that the
cmo
would assist you with but
there is that advisory capacity you know
again you don't want to reinvent the
wheel
so
working with a cmo
from the start of a development
can significantly reduce risk
um
and i really can't stress enough that
what can work in r d
may not translate onto the large
automated lateral flow manufacturing
equipment you know so for example
the materials you initially choose
for the r d work
may be perfectly fine in terms of uh
uh flow rate for the sample um
to move
through the test
you may see a nice positive line and
when you get to that point within a
development if you if you develop a
sandwich i'll say but
the worst case scenario is
that material perhaps under the
cellulose membrane the material that
you've chosen it simply lacks the
tensile strength that it can't be used
on a really automated system you know
and again having to change something
at a late stage in development or as
you're transferring to manufacturing
is going to be costly in terms of
money
and and time so you know
i do i do everyone listening to to
really consider using a cmo
to save you time and money and don't be
invent the wheel
if the cmo will have advice
we'll
know
the best options in terms of you know
that sample matrix
that type of test that you want to
develop and manufacture
and as an advisory role you know can
really make a positive impact
so
this diagram
really
um
illustrates some of the
typical stages if you're like during a
uh
development pathway for a lateral flow
assay you know so
where where in our pathway you know
should you involve a cmo well i mean
ultimately it's your it's your choice
um
talking from personal experience uh from
an abbott and health
perspective
as a cmo we can be involved right to the
beginning um
so if
a customer for example decides to
outsource not just the manufacturing but
if it's a you know if flash or flow is
non-core to the r d team you know they
may decide to outsource some of that
risk of the development um and outsource
the r d
to us also so and obviously that's gonna
if that's possible you know it's gonna
depend whether your cmo of choice um is
purely manufacturing
or also has a development capability
also so for example as i said in case in
some cases we can be evolved from the
very early stage proof of concept and we
operate a system here which is i think
it's common to uh
many companies um
within
the rapid testing sector essentially
it's a very modular approach with
feasibility to optimization to scale up
to technical transfer so
where
your test may fit
into our pathway you know will be
dictated by how much work how much r d
has obviously been done prior to it
coming in to us as a contra
manufacturing organization so
typically if a test has been developed
it may be uh
developed up to the end of optimization
and it's then time to scale up
and then
transfer for
routine routine manufacturing so
that's a very common approach uh that
scale up is basically necessary so for
example within r d um
you may have been manufacturing tests uh
on a very sort of bench scale uh
bench top
process
and perhaps there's been no um uh
no testing of of that initial disorder
of that design on you know common
biodog realtor real system um you know
in terms of
in terms of the autolaminator et cetera
so that scalar processing is is very
important to make sure that
what's being done at an r d scale uh can
be scaled up effectively onto the
manufacturing equipment and it's from
there then moving moving to the uh
technical transfer and then ultimately
routine manufacturing
but again this is something that your uh
cmo should be aware of
and you and really it's
it's your choice
but
your cmo should be prepared
um you know to be involved at those
earlier stages even if it is from um
an advisory
uh perspective
just to make sure as we said previously
you know the
materials that the odds that you're
looking at um the processes that you're
considering to manufacture they are all
suitable for high throughput routine
manufacturing
so if we talk about a little bit uh
further and look at it in a bit more
depth really
so
where should you involve the schema well
one thing for me
is materials so
you could look at it as
what does successful
manufacturing involve you know from a
lateral flow i say well
um
[Music]
you conjugate your labels on your
antibodies effectively those labels
could be uh gold nanoparticles and they
could be the goal could be spherical it
could be nanorods it could be looking at
cellulose
beads could be looking at fluorescent
particles
platinum carbon you know there's
latex there's a whole host of particles
you know obviously you want the best
particle
for your particular test
so you conjugate the labels to the
antibodies effectively you know you
select and and apply the the right
reagents it's impossible surfactants
things in those nature and components so
you know like your cells membrane you
want your sample part your conjugate pad
your upper wick assemble all that into a
housing make sure they all work together
um you know to deliver tests according
to your uh quality specifications i mean
sounds easy doesn't it you know but um i
think we all know that
the
in each choice in each element
within those multiple working parts of
the lateral flow assay if if you don't
get that particular component right
there will be a knock on there will be a
knock on effect if if that
if if that the issue with that component
carries on through development
you may come to the point we want to
transfer to manufacturing and your cmo
may point out immediately look
we've used
we've we've used that particular
material in the past we know we know it
causes problems x y and z
now
you then have a choice
the test can be manufactured as is with
that element you know and
and really um you know
accepting that element of risk of that
particular component or there's that
uh choice there to
spend
time money to swap that opponent out so
so again having the cmo in involved you
know at a relatively
early stage
you can make use of the cmos experience
and and really there's no need as i've
said previously um and forgive me if i
repeat this number numerous times
no need to
reinvent the wheel
if you're cmo
that you've chosen
you know has the experience and the
expertise when it comes not only to
manufacturing tests but also what's
developing
tests and they will be able to assist
you
with all with all of these um
areas that really should be considered
you know so for example
there's a as you can imagine there's a
huge variety of different of uh
sample matrices depending on
what the test is going to analyze and
who the end user is going to be
so if a test is being developed and it's
whole milk there's that high fat content
to consider
if it's whole blood you know you want to
strip strip out the red blood cells so
it could potentially mask
the red test light if it was in gold
there's a whole host of um things that
you can say i mean saliva uh
the the number of times i i i've been
you know i've been in a meeting and
we're talking about the development and
plus manufacturing of a saliva matrix
based test you know and
people will always sort of agree with
that sort of right smile that you know
yes you think saliva should be an easy
sample matrix because it's 98 water
uh it's the other two percent that
causes all of all of the challenges
really to uh uh overcome so
what are the best materials to allow
high throughput automated production
because
if you if you plan on um supplying in
into your market you know 100 200 500
000 tests
a month you don't was made by hand you
know um
you wanted to be as automated as
possible to drive down drive on the
manufacturing cost you know and to take
away
as much potential human error as
possible
now in terms of those materials
does just does your cmo of choice have
long term supply agreements now
this is
this has become
an important important factor really
during this year you know because
there has been such a demand from a wide
variety of companies to develop a covey
19 test you know so
luckily uh
we've been in this game long enough that
that we have very good relationships you
know with uh major sailors membrane
suppliers uh suppliers of sample pads
you know backing card
etc that we are we already have those
agreements in in in place and we can
work with with our vendors and to um
to assist us if our demand
in
increases now
um you know i shouldn't wouldn't want to
be in a position this year of suddenly
going out to the market looking for a
supply period next to sellers
membrane when
it was a huge demand for that particular
material so there may have been stock
issues
the i mean the other thing to bear in
mind um in terms of uh
osmo having a robust supply chain you
know not only that no risk to the
continuity of of supply number but for
example
any uh
any required changes in uh material
perhaps i think is being discontinued
you know so you need a cmo to be
have that relationship
with the supplier to be able to manage
those those component changes you know
and we need to again to be your uh eyes
and ears within the market not to know
if there's something that's approaching
on the horizon and it could impact you
know
the material you need to produce your
test then having that relationship
having that knowledge beforehand you
know can go a long way to uh minimize
any any negative impact
you know and again i know something that
i missed previously but just having that
and having that experience having that
expertise to know well are those
components that have been selected
are they suitable for
automated
manufacturing
so again uh you know
where should we where should you involve
uh your chosen schema well
a good cmo will not only have experience
and
an expertise but
they also have those processes
in in place so
using your cmo at a relatively early
stage you know prior to a test
transferring in and will ensure that the
assets being developed can be
transferred in
efficiently
and within
a really optimized
time frame
so to get that test into routine
manufacturing get that test out to your
to your customers
so again you don't want to be
reinventing the wheel you know um you
want to use those sort of tried and
tested processes and procedures that
as i mentioned previously where's it
i've been done the same procedures and
processes we use for our average and
health branded products are those that
are applied to our uh contract
manufacturing
tests
and you know it's going to mean that
those
critical process parameters and control
points associated with the process with
the equipment and already going to be
defined you know and um
the
those plot processes
is going to provide a reproducible and
robust manufacturing you know process
the last thing you want
is to have errors
quality problems batch after match of
the batchman that just should not be the
situation
whatsoever
so
by involving your cmo at the newly point
within the product development you know
keep in those touch part touch points as
the development proceeds
we are
going to use um and you know we are
going to make use of
your uh
cmos expertise experience and their
existing
automation on their existing equipment
again reducing the uh reducing the
requirement for you to spend time and
money putting these things in place
i'm sure you sure you yeah you're aware
um
lateral flow and immunoassays or
lots of fluorescency tests can be
manufactured by hand you know but
through team
manufacturing you you really want that
to be automated as much as as much as
possible by working with a cmo at an
early point
you you're going to know
you know you you're going to have that
um input from a cmo regarding well
in terms of a test design
what is suitable for automation
what is not so things that we need to be
considered um as you can imagine the
equipment to be employed to manufacture
you know
the r d batches perhaps in in-house
um how does that equipment compare into
the matter of fact the manufacturing
equipment your cmo will use so as i
mentioned um
how does your equipment compare to for
example uh the buyer dot relative real
reagent dispensers uh auto lamination
equipment
things of that nature
and ultimately
how translatable
is
your r d production
to routine production with within within
the cmo okay so
again
have having those conversations
um having input from your cmo at the
particular points through through the
development
you're really gonna all that prep work
is going to be done so
what you want from the cmo then is an
efficient
fast
optimized transfer to manufacturing okay
nobody likes any surprises essentially
i've mentioned technical transfer
a number of times i mean in many cases
um
this is actually where
we
would
anticipate seeing tests that you know
that may have been developed elsewhere
may or may already be uh uh commercially
available and there's a requirement to
transfer them in to a symbol so it's
basically a process where you verify
that manufacturing that routine
manufacturing process um
is suitable you know and it really
basically spit the two areas uh you know
i'm sure that you're aware of this in
terms of batch manufacturing so
accurate reproducible and robust assay
that allows
repeatable batches to be to be produced
and to meet the quality criteria
so typically um
we would
we would kind of three
uh manufacturing three transfer transfer
batches
there's also that documentation element
to it obviously to make the batch
records are are completely which
which
can go into uh
the necessary
technical dossiers perhaps used for uh
regulatory purposes
and i know i think a key element is that
you know obviously your cmo has to take
the lead with regard to this process um
it's in the cmo's interest to
move that test into routine into into
routine manufacturing you know and i i
can't think of any cmo that would want
to
um
purposely extend that technical transfer
process you know but
a good cmo will will also also resist
the temptation to cut corners you know
because you really have to demonstrate
repeatable production
of batches in terms of quality in terms
of not only the product but also also
the
repeatability and robustness of the
process
in place you know and
cutting any corners is just the recipe
for disaster further on down the line so
i i would urge everyone to really
as a slight suggest to take the lead
from the cmo with regard to what's
required for
technical transfer
so i think we've um
you probably heard me say this
uh a number of times you know but
if you can
uh you know talk to your the or even if
you haven't thought about
manufacturing you know i say you know
yet i mean speak to companies involved
in this field um
even if it's
primarily for
uh
advisory
input um
it's it's going to be worth it it's
going to be worth your while and um
by working with that cmo you know and
having that cmo
in place ready to accept the test post
development
for for manufacturing it is really
really going to assist in that
development process you know and really
make sure the quality management system
that the cmo is working to is
suitable
however and the
one thing
i would i mean i would always i i i
would always suggest people to research
and before choosing a cmo you know is
what do they offer except
manufacturing i mean the um
the cmo should
be your at least your eyes and ears
within within the market you know so
in terms of you know helping you through
that's a regulatory and commercial
landscape so
what ready what regulatory support is
there now you may find um
you may find a company can develop a
lateral fluorescein it can manufacture a
lateral flow assay up to a certain patch
size
company may develop the tests may
manufacture and you know up to the batch
size you know 500 000 test plus um
you may find other companies that purely
all they do is contract manufacturing
now
what your the question you also have to
ask is you know well
what can you how can you support me in
terms of that commercial and regulatory
landscape now something i'm
i think we're
very fortunate within abundant is
because we've developed and manufactured
our own tests and we have had to make
that investment in terms of a very
strong qa
and ra department
so we can support our customers in terms
of current and future regulation
will that be some fd fda's of uh
510k that obviously should be um
extra marks if anyone noticed that
before me um ce marking and you know
the imminent implementation of uh
ivdi so so
as you know by i think i think by the
26th of may 2022 um
all ivds sold in the year you don't need
to adhere to the new uh
ivd
r i think it's 2017
forward stroke 746 so you know which
replaces the original ivd now
it's thought that this will impact 80
percent of ivds actually sold
within the years and so so your cmo
should
already you know have been
very much uh not only aware of of what's
coming down the road you know but
working with their customers to
assist them in what needs to be done
what changes need to be done um
to get those tests marked market ready
now
you'll see the cmo may also
have the capability you know to and to
be at the
legal manufacture status on on your
behalf you know so but
there's no there's those
other areas that the cmo can assist also
you know so um packaging solutions you
know it's it at some points actually
getting the test device assembled into a
file pouch where the desk and label is
that
may be
almost the easiest part of of that
process you know you've then well what
about all the peripheral
components
etc so
perhaps you use your cmo within the
development process to advise and assist
on well
what's going to be the
optimal sample collection method sample
treatment what componentry
would be required what are those sort of
commercial um aspects that need to be
considered so
potential
distribution uh channels you know
even supporting you within commercial
negotiation so there's a whole variety
of um
aspects where the cmos your chosen cmo
should be able to assist you with you
know and be much more than just a
manufacturer
so i would just like to take uh
a couple of minutes just to really give
you
um a bit of a case study here which
really shows
all areas however cmo um
can
assist
assist you so
this um
relates to the abc19
rapid test so
this is something that we undertook as
part of the uh uk europa test consortium
um
taking on the
lead manufacturer um status
so
we were involved from a very early stage
in that developing the test you know
which was really done
um an exceptional uh timeline in in
terms of
um that development development process
you know and you you could argue the
point well if it can be done for this
test it could be done from for other
tests but um this was really a sort of
valid effort from from colleagues with
within r d and and tech transfer you
know sort of working around the clock
split shifts um and really applying as
much resource as was needed to get this
important test
developed you know so it's essentially
um
an antibody test looking at the uh igg
for use
through um
[Music]
the population
uh
whole blood
fingerprint test now
this is
this is an area where
we've been involved as i said in the
development
we have
uh we
we
with other consortium members will be
manufacturing
the test but we've also
been pivotal in terms of the regulatory
aspects so really taking on all of those
uh
necessary
um
workflow requirements
to facilitate this test being developed
manufactured
and out into the market where you know
it's it's
it
it's a very important test that is
needed to uh
respond to
current events
so
i guess in um
i guess all i can do is thank you for
your attention um
you know i i hope you will i hope you
found this uh interesting and
informative i look forward to
any questions
and thank you for your attention
jonathan thank you for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of our presentation so now as a
reminder to our audience please submit
your questions via the q a box
jonathan our first question
if you had to give someone one piece of
advice about developing a test for
manufacturing
what would it be
um
i think the best piece of advice
i could possibly get would be don't
don't cut corners um
the
will always be
the
um
the option from you know from
from some development companies some
manufacturing companies or even internal
pressure you know to
really speed things along uh you know
because ultimately to get the test out
into the marketplace to start generating
uh
revenue but often that can be you know
a recipe for disaster essentially and so
um
any any development pathway you know
there will be
elements of that of that development
which can run in parallel if the if if
sufficient technical resource is is
available
but
wherever there's the temptation you know
to perhaps actually well we just
live with the the potential risk of
not doing x y and z in the development
and then we do them at the end if need
be then
that can just
you know it is just just uh kicking the
can down the road and there could be a
whole host of unwelcome surprises when
you are ready to transfer it into
manufacturing that have to be remedied
at that point
sure thank you
what size batches should be produced
when a test is transferred into
manufacturing
um
the one thing to bear in mind um
well i mean just to give you the sort of
habit of the health
approach so
we would manufacture uh three validation
of three transfer batches now we tend to
take the approach of so
low
medium which is probably not not the
right words to use really but
the one thing that should all that
should always be the goal is that third
and final validation batch should be at
the anticipated um
routine production batch size
so that will that will be based on
the customers initial sales forecast
the reason being
you you want to demonstrate that that
test can be manufactured um in
a repeatable way but
it can be manufactured at the scale it
is going to be done on a routine basis
so
you don't want to transfer a test
manufacturer and say for
10 000 you know a batch size of 10 000
tests and then within a couple of months
there's the realization that the test
has taken off in in in the market and
actually a hundred thousand tests are
needed per batch and there's a whole
host of things to look at then in terms
of conjugate stability um qc procedures
etcetera you know and they can't be an
element of work then to scale up to the
required routine batch size so
low medium high
but that sort of high if you like is the
routine batch size
thank you for that answer now we have
some great questions coming in so i want
to make sure we have time to answer them
let's go with this next one um great job
john
given the current pandemic there seems
to be a lack of cmo capacity globally
does abington health have capacity to
take on new projects
yeah i mean it's it can be a challenge
it can certainly it can certainly depend
on
current production schedules except i
mean we're very conscious that we have
um
we have
customers that have been with us have
been done
before the pandemic and will be with us
after the pandemic so
we certainly
have made sure that
those customers have been prioritized to
to maintain that continuity of supply
but i mean it's one of the reasons why
um uh our ceo chris says took the
um some
decision we need to invest
make sure we invest in the
infrastructure
into the manufacturing capacity
equipment footprint so we i think by the
end of this year we should be up to a
million tests a week to party and
there'll be uh i think there's another
expansion um planned for next year to
take that further so there
is
capacity available i mean you know it's
very it
it it is in high demand um
but we are approaching it you know with
a sort of cool head and um
you know
very methodical mahana really you know
so to make sure that the orders are in
um customers are fully aware it's very
transparent as to what the lead time is
is going to be and
we've been looking at um
modified sort of weapons etc so not just
bringing in extra equipment but we but
we've also uh greatly increased the uh
the workforce within those areas to make
sure the capacity is there
that's great to hear
good
our next question
let's see um
are you able to help new startup with
guidance on how to obtain grants funding
in order to help them get through the
development process for example with
gays foundation submissions
um yes yes i mean we can you know we um
we have a long history of with a wide
variety of um companies are from from
spin outs from universities through to
well multinationals so yeah i mean if
foreign
i can i can respond to them
directly with my contact details and
yeah you know
we could certainly have a chat and uh if
i can advise them or a colleague
great and we do have all of everyone's
email addresses for those who are
submitting questions so any questions we
are unable to answer today and any of
the questions that come in during the
on-demand period
uh you will be able to answer those via
email
so
we have time for just maybe two more so
let's squeeze a couple in here um
does abington do microfluidic cartridges
too and would you have a recommended cmo
for microfluidics
um
we don't currently um
again i went offline and speak with some
colleagues um
and
there may be some companies
suggest you know we're very sort of
collaborative
within within the industry and
there's lots of uh
[Music]
lots of possible connections there
that we
that we can call upon so yeah i'll
reply to that person then if if we can't
help or if we can finish see anywhere
great
and um let's go with this question
because it seems like a very popular
topic in 2020 right now obviously um
currently are you still being approached
to develop tests that are non-coded
related
absolutely yes and um i i must confess
when we are you know it's it's an
absolute breath of fresh air you know it
it seems to have been everything's been
covered related since it seems all you
doesn't it so um yes yeah i mean there
are still tests um
being developed out there which uh
nothing to do with
uh with 19 and we have and we
want recently started and um
yeah and there's a couple more
to do to start shortly so yeah
it's still going on
great
and jonathan we have time for one more
question so let's wrap with this one
if customers wish to transfer their
design into you for manufacture
do you have a preferred suppliers you'd
prefer to work with
for reagents pads membranes etc or are
you open in your approach to whatever
works best in the development
yeah so um
a term we often use is we are
in theory particle materials
agnostic so you know it's
very much a case of
looking
what has been used perhaps to develop in
the test development before it comes in
before it comes into abundance um
we have very strong relationships with
all of the main suppliers um
not just for
the sort of usual sort of suspect in
terms of religious materials but also
housings
etc
so
we would very much be focused on
what's best for the test
what
what's best
to um
deliver a test in which meets those uh
initials of test specifications is it's
going to deliver a test which meets the
end user requirements
but we certainly wouldn't be
um looking to crowbar in
a particular material you know in into
that test
um you know we we don't actually
manufacture so nanoparticles ourselves
and so we're
very much open to
what's the best material to fit that
test
specification and
what we've done previously if they can
be improved if there is something that
we know of and we certainly will discuss
that with the customer and um you know
and
a decision can then be made
but we certainly wouldn't be looking to
change things for the sake of it
great
and jonathan unfortunately we're out of
time we had so many great questions
coming in there's quite a few that we
weren't able to answer
but do you have any final comments for
our audience
um
i mean the uh
i think
we're going to i think
a lot more people are now um aware of
lateral flow assays um
there's probably been a mix in the media
of sort of good reviews bad reviews and
based on
current
world events and um i think
where where there's there may be
negative press i mean i think that's
primarily down to
um
corners being cut
um
things not being thought through
completely and you know and test being
rushed out onto the market okay so i
it's a
it's
and i say um type which is going to be
with us again for you know for decades
as it has been um previously and um i
think
for the industry that there's certainly
a challenge in but also exciting
few years ahead of us
sure
that makes sense
um
so jonathan thank you so much uh so
appreciate your time
um i wanted to remind you thank you and
i do we want to remind our audience that
those questions that we did not answer
and any of those that are submitted
during the on-demand period they will be
addressed via email
um
yeah so this presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing
i just want to remind you to share with
your colleagues who might be interested
in today's topic and don't miss out on
other presentations on our agenda
thank you again for
participating and we hope you have a
great day thanks for joining us